okay so let us know in the comments
which one of us should cheat on our
significant other
then tune back in to find out what
happens we'll see you then on every damn
day okay great job guys Brian good work
we'll cut around you so just remind of
the office luau is today at 4:00
can we bring us on to our office day
party yeah Tom you figure there's so
much thinking about those obstacles Oh
Hannah that's nice you're probably a
little brother don't be an ass Brian
it's chill I'm gonna take a piss
wait what did I say is that not your
little brother are you dumb
Spencer is my boyfriend he looks like a
young elf no he just seems young because
he's a series regular on a Disney
Channel show
he's pop collar Chas wait he's like 14
they're on the show Disney stars are
like 22 probably maybe he's a clone
heard everybody's getting close in
Hollywood cloning is hot right now
know what a 14-year old have enough
money to have his own driver porch and
yard one hundred percent up their own
driver cuz legally they cannot drive no
people just do everything for him
because he's a celebrity or maybe he's
incapable of basic tasks because he's a
child you bought your own beer because
you can do that and I got it for free
and it's it's not a beer it's a Mike's
Hard Lemonade
so Spence where do you live friend's
parents and my mother lives with me so
you live with your mom whoa okay
someone's a little jealous of me my mom
lives with me she couldn't afford her
own place in the city and I had already
bought a three-bedroom condo in cash I
think it's so amazing that you can do
okay I'm sorry this is disgusting excuse
me bro
no I just meant YouTube together really
cool you're gonna body say my woman
right in front of me his body has
nothing to do with this what's your
teeth yeah no oh because she farts in
her sleep
it's not her fault she completely lacks
self-control when it comes to lactose
okay she loves cottage cheese she loves
it
oh stop it you're really gonna sign this
asshole after he called you disgusting
get out pop caller Chazz doesn't need
this I just checked his Wikipedia page
he's 34 oh that is disgusting
[Music]
you